hi guys this is Peter in this video I'm
gonna talk about some of the best places
to travel to in Pakistan I was fortunate
enough to be there a few months back I
made a ten part series on the country
now obviously I didn't see everything I
was there for two weeks as an outsider
as a foreigner so this is a foreigners
perspective but let me show you what I
thought to be the best of the country
Wagah border crossing if you're in the
hore it's about 45 minutes to an hour
away if you're in India you might be
coming over this crossing now this is a
surreal place like nothing else in the
world it's a very unique cocktail of
machismo ballet pride tribalism
patriotism nationalism aggression and
sportsmanship in a way the ceremony
symbolizes everything that sucks about
humanity and everything that is
beautiful about it at the same time
Lahore Lahore is a very fascinating city
you you have to go here if you go to
Pakistan it's a very interesting mix of
intensity and soulful relaxed energy put
some time into the Lahore for in the
mughal architecture it's a peaceful and
powerful place plus you'll probably meet
a lot of locals there and it's quiet so
you can actually engage in some
conversations and hear what people are
saying it's it's a really cool place to
spend at least a half-day then I suggest
going outside of the for going into the
old city the old walled city pumping
some pavement on your own and just
getting lost in some of the streets
the [ __ ] old city is a gem it's a
timeless stew of culture I'm not one for
hiring guides but I did my last day in
the city the old city is very detailed
and complex and a good guide can really
help you understand it better I'll leave
a link to the guide I used in the
description his name's a deal very
passionate energetic interesting guy and
he'll bring you into a lahore there's no
way you'd be able to see on your own yes
Lahore is a new and modern part to it
with highways chain restaurants and
shopping malls if that's your thing
but for me Lahore is all about the deep
soulful culture of the old city in
Lahore street food
is fantastic Islamabad Islamabad is the
Pakistani city that most Westerners
wouldn't think would be in Pakistan wide
boulevards lots of big spaces low
population density Islamabad felt more
to me like a green phoenix arizona'
suburb with strip malls new gas stations
and car culture so don't go there if
you're looking for deep culture go there
if you want less horns less chaos and a
more relaxed Pakistani city with
beautiful nature nearby Hunza Valley
Hunza Valley is one of the treasures of
the world it's got the views but it also
has a very rich culture honza has three
distinct languages that are spoken in
different parts of the valley and many
different ethnicities living there since
so many empires have come through this
remote land it's properly mixed up and
you'll see diversity like you're in a
big western city but instead you're in a
remote mountainous region near the
Afghani Indian and Chinese borders and
they've got something up there in Hunza
that so much of the modern world is
missing it's the University of Lahore
hear me out it's not your your typical
University this is a place where a lot
of guys get together instead of studying
and taking tests they're playing games
they're laughing they're singing they're
joking around no screens around just
really good connectivity that
connectivity we all sort of longed for
they've got it they have it in spades up
there
[Music]
this place looked somewhat like a biker
bar in the mojave desert of california
things are organic and hones us so the
food quality is exceptional
I had a yak meal that was super
delicious pesho' are theirs hospitality
and then there's Peshawar this place is
all heart and all war coming on friendly
terms and receive open arms and love
come in as an enemy and good luck
pressure wires like leverage when it's
in your favor it does amazing things and
when it's not it works against you in
multiples Peshawar was the Gateway to
the Indian subcontinent and the oldest
city in Pakistan founded in 539 BCE the
city has seen its fair share of battles
and blood and I'm not sure how
hospitality sprouts from such a history
but it does the Pashtun people are
generally more conservative so be
respectful of that if you're cool to
them they will reward you let me know
it's a fairly good-sized city everyone
seemed to know everyone it was very very
well connected where we going how do you
mean I really would like to see you okay
they're gonna look at me through the
through the screen okay
so what am I supposed to do look here
love it so cool really cool and I'm
really loving the Pashtun people really
it's my first day in Peshawar will you
come again
yes inshallah hey guys
[Music]
okay we're gonna go further down the
rabbit hole Karachi
if Karachi was an instrument it would be
a bass drum nowhere that I've seen on
this planet moves to such an intense
beat it's the biggest city in the
melting pot of Pakistan everyone from
all over the country can come here and
find their place and make a life for
themselves it's also a beast of a city
so when you get into the center of it
the heaviness is tangible with that said
it's very hospitable people are glad
you're there the city was the fifth most
dangerous city in the world roughly six
years ago but things have gotten much
safer in recent years this isn't to say
that Karachi doesn't have an edge to it
because it does it feels like it's it's
hanging right on the edge but that edge
is what makes the city so alive and so
exciting depending on your personality
you might get irritated but you'll never
be bored in a way Karachi and Islamabad
are at the opposite ends of the spectrum
those are the places I went to in the
country a very diverse selection here
are a few themes I learned along the way
safety people have asked me is Pakistan
safe to travel - I'd say for the most
part it's very safe people are very
helpful super hospitable you're never
gonna be alone that said they're bad
characters in every country every
culture in the world there are a few
parts of the country away from the major
destinations that you want to have more
knowledge of before you venture into
them but overall Pakistan one of the
true benefits is it's a place where
people for the most part do not rip you
off
it's a giving culture people have the
impulse to give to you they don't expect
anything in return but try to give back
when you can
English is very easy to use in the
cities it also works very well in Hunza
Valley the police and the Rangers the
Rangers are the the border security guys
very easy to deal with very helpful I
don't know behind the scenes I don't
know the history not a local
I don't know how corrupt things are but
from my perspective it was
exceptional a very seamless experience
on the security front it's a passionate
culture don't go in there picking deeply
into politics listen a lot there's a lot
to learn in Pakistan it's it's it's
beautiful it's heartbreaking it's a bit
of everything but it's it's a lesson the
country's been through a lot
it also gives a lot you'll hear some of
the most surprising things like I would
like to give a very sophisticated a
message to the president of America
Donald Trump we love him and we love the
way here
what Pakistan is about is the people the
people really shine in this country they
really give you a lot and if you go in
open you will receive warmth like very
few places on the planet Western press
has done a great job of demonizing the
country so you have a lot of tourists
here or no no it is not much but before
9/11 you have used to have a lot of
tourists here Wow instill there they're
scared to come here you are from USA you
know you know about the media of course
what kind of image Pakistan have
terrible one yeah if you're thinking of
going don't just listen to me
do your research just 2020 so there's
everything you want online about
Pakistan I was a little skeptical going
in you can't help you know with the
conditioning you've been conditioned
your whole life in a certain way even
though I was open-minded enough I did
enough research I knew things we could
find it can't help but have a few
reservations so that's normal but just
do your research and you'll realize
right now Pakistan 2020 for the most
part the majority of the country is very
stable and safe to travel in so this is
the last video for the Pakistan series
for those of you that watched that liked
that commented that were part of the
journey thank you so much I really
enjoyed it
it was a lot
fun I did my editing here in heave
Ukraine in my apartment grinded away
late into the night and it was one of my
coolest travel experiences and I'd
wanted to go to the country for many
years and it exceeded my expectations
and I'm glad I captured a lot of that in
these videos so if you haven't seen any
of the videos any of these places I just
talked about go down below in the
description I'll have a link to the
Pakistani playlist and that's it for now
thank you so much thanks for being part
of this thanks for watching and I hope
to see you in the next video
you